it's a new iteration of the wii sports
series
nintendo switch sports
let's begin with these three sports
you might recognize them from past wii
sports games
[Music]
tennis rally by gently swinging the
joy-con controller at the right time
bowling roll the ball straight ahead or
give it a little curve
[Music]
and chambra
knock your opponent off the platform
while attacking and defending
plus three additional sports are joining
the lineup
[Music]
soccer
use a gigantic ball to make dynamic
plays
enjoy matches with joy-con controllers
to shoot and perform diving headers
by attaching a joy-con controller to the
leg strap accessory included with the
physical version of the game you can
play shootout mode with intuitive
kicking motion
badminton
control your shots left and right while
keeping the shuttlecock in the air
unleash powerful smash shots to gain the
upper hand
[Music]
finally volleyball
use a joy-con controller to serve
bump
set
and spike the ball
[Music]
the game supports local play with family
and friends on one nintendo switch
system as well as online play across all
sports
play against friends online
or opt for random matchmaking the more
you win the tougher the players you'll
face
try taking on this challenge
[Music]
the nintendo switch sports game launches
april 29th
a free update is scheduled for this
summer that lets you play soccer matches
with the joy-con controller and the leg
strap accessory you can use the
accessory to play shootout mode at
launch
in addition
a second free update that lets you enjoy
golf
will launch this fall
plus an online play test is planned
before launch to evaluate various
technical aspects
it will only be available for players
with an active nintendo switch online
membership for the dates shown on screen
if you're interested please visit the
official nintendo website for more
details
you